All right, short video here to just go over this 12 lead EKG reference that
we've put together. So this first page on the document is just an overview of all
the different steps that it walks us through. So basically just takes us from
identifying that we want to perform a 12 lead and walks us through all the
different steps we might need to perform along the way. So we'll get into the
details in just a moment. I just wanted to show you how it's all laid out from
the get-go. Now the goals of this document, the first one is just to
compile all the different miscellaneous EKG and 12 lead interpretation
references that we've come across in the last few years. So we've had just a bunch
of like notes on our phone and tabs bookmarked in our browsers and that sort
of thing, but we try to put them all into one place. The other thing that we tried
to do is answer a few pointed questions. So in here when we're assessing on step
three, assessing for an MI, some of the questions that we specifically wanted to
dig into. One is how to match these occlusive myocardium fargshin or OMI
patterns with the things that we've been taught. So in the STEMI paradigm we've
all been taught like how to identify where st-elevations correlate to on the
myocardium and then like which vessels are affected. We wanted to do something
similar for the different OMI patterns and then also both for the STEMI
paradigm and for the OMI paradigm. Once we identify those things, how do we need
to change our treatment? Are there interventions that we need to perform or
things we need to do differently once we identify these patterns? So that's the
idea behind this document. So first page is just an overview. There's a couple
of resources mentioned here and we'll talk about more of these along the way.
Let's just take a look and see how it looks. So it starts out very basic. How to
identify when we need to do a 12 lead. There's some like risk stratification
tools here. It also talks about assessing our rhythm in lead two before we dive
into doing a 12 lead. So there are some things that we can identify immediately
and address right away even before we get into the 12 lead. So those those are
listed here. The next thing we got here and I've opened it up in a window for us
to take a look at but it basically shows if we have identified that the patient
is high risk for an EMI so they have concerning signs and symptoms like
you know shortness of breath, diaphoresis, chest pain. It kind of like outlines the
risk of how likely they are to have an EMI based on their initial presenting
rhythm. So some of this might be intuitive but I think it's worth focusing
in on because we can quite quickly get caught up in like doing a 12 lead when
we don't need to or being concerned about a finding that we don't really
need to be concerned about. So for example if you have V-TAC or V-Fib we
probably don't need to be messing around with doing a 12 lead right now. We need
to fix those things. If we have a patient who's presenting with signs and symptoms
of chest pain or of an EMI and they have PVCs like this may be concerning if
they're happening frequently or increasing the frequency but if they're
just baseline have a couple PVCs and we probably don't need to be that concerned.
Anyways that's what this initial chart here was set up to demonstrate. Moving on
from there it goes over you know placing your leads, assessing ST segments. That's
all stuff that you probably already know but it's good to have a backup. Let's say
for example you want someone else on scene like a first responder to help you
do a 12 lead. You can just open this up and show them the picture and that
directs them to where to put the leads on a patient. The next section here
talks about ruling out STEMI mimics. So these are things that present with ST
elevation but aren't actually indicative of a coronary artery inclusion. So
there's a couple things here. One is this raised ST segment mnemonic and you can
actually click this link here and it opens up a full PDF document that goes
into specifics on each one of these points. And then these bottom two are
screenshots from two really good references. One is from a website called
OMI guide which you can again click on the link and open up. The other one is
from an app called the OMI toolbox and there are links here for you to download
it if you feel inclined after this. But let's take a look at these real quick
just to show you what they're all about. So the first one is this STEMI mimics
mnemonic. So this is the picture that we put in the document but if you scroll
down there are detailed explanations for each and every one of these points.
So if you see one of these things that let's say you see SD segment elevation
and you want to make sure it's not where you want to see if you can attribute it
to a cause other than an occlusion or an MI this is a good place to start. So
that's what this one's all about and we don't have to go into all the details
there. The other one here this OMI pocket guide again this is a website but
you can also like set up a shortcut on your phone to use it as a progressive
web app but basically it has its own take on SD elevation that is not
indicative or is a mimic of an occlusion MI. So if you click on any one of these
it kind of opens up into a more detailed explanation that gives you examples and
links to studies and everything that you know everything you need to look further
into these ideas. So that's the STEMI mimic section. The next bit here is about
assessing for OMI patterns. So you're probably familiar with this idea this
like kind of a new paradigm to replace what we're calling the STEMI paradigm. So
OMI is for occlusive myocardial infarction and it's a more specific way
to identify if what we're seeing on our 12 lead is indicative of an occlusion in
coronary artery. So there are lots of different patterns that indicates OMI
in different regions of the heart. So this image here is from like one of the
most exhaustive references like this but it's not totally all inclusive so we've
included a couple others as well. So let's say you have a patient who presents
with signs and symptoms concerning for an MI. You don't see any of the
traditional ST segment changes but you're pretty sure they have something.
You can use any of these resources to kind of like identify patterns that
might indicate that your patient is having an actual heart attack. We don't
have to get into the specifics here there's lots of good content out there
these days about the OMI paradigm and all of these different tools that you
can use to assess for them but we've just included some of them here and we
made a couple a couple notes along the way just to help you along. So the next
step is once we've identified a concerning pattern traditionally what
we've done in the STEMI paradigm is we've correlated those ST segment
changes to a specific geographic region on the heart and then from there we've
correlated that with a culprit vessel like which coronary artery is occluded.
We haven't really been taught super well how to do that on the OMI side so
that's what this chart is all about. So it kind of shows here on the left the
different OMI patterns that we might see and then the next column in the
middle here shows the blood supply that is affected by those patterns and then
the areas of the heart in the last column the areas of the heart that are
affected. So this kind of like takes this idea of identifying the geographic
region and the culprit vessel and lays it on top of all these different OMI
patterns. So that's what we've got there. The next two charts here these are big
ones so we'll zoom in on each of these. The first one here just kind of takes
this STEMI paradigm set of patterns that we've been looking at and adds some
columns over on the right. So we identify the area affected we identify the blood
supply and then we identify what other structures might be affected and then
based on that we can adjust our treatment as necessary and then look out
for possible complications. Okay let's work through one specific example here
just to show you the idea that we're trying to get it here. So let's say we
have SD segment changes indicative of infarct on the lateral wall so we're on
the second row here. Most likely vessel affected would be our left circumflex
and then other branches of the LED. Other structures that might be affected would
be the left atrium, papillary muscles and then the conduction system in general.
Things we might want to do different in our treatment would be to consider
listening to heart tones. Now we don't routinely listen to heart tones in the
pre-hospital setting or even with our MI patients in the field but with a lateral
wall in mind you could potentially have papillary muscle rupture and mitral
regurgitation. So this might be one of those situations where like maybe we do
need to take a moment and give a listen. So that is just a quick example of how
we might change our treatments based on anticipated complications. We've done
something similar for the OMI pattern. So as an example here let's go down here
to the... let's say we have this terminal QRS distortion in V2 and V3. So this is
indicative of an LED occlusion so it'll affect the anterior wall. Other
structures that might be affected would be the conduction system in general and
the papillary muscles. So you might want to use caution if we have to give fluids
and then things we want to look out for would be LV dysfunction, cardiogenic shock,
heart failure, pulmonary edema, alvethrombus, and then ventricular
arrhythmias. So that's kind of how you can use these two charts to direct your
treatments as you work through these things. Alright so let's go back to
the document here. So that's what these giant charts are and then because this
one here is a lot of information on one page we took out a couple columns here
and just this one is the same information but we removed the affected
arteries and the geographic region and we just show the pattern scene and then
the structure you know we just took out some columns there to make it easier for
you to see. Other things we have on our guide here is if you had to do a
right-sided or a posterior view kind of walks you through how to do those. We
also have some other things you might see on your 12 lead just for reference.
So these are some patterns that could predispose a patient to having a lethal
dysrhythmia V-TAC or V-Fib. We got a little quick reference on bundled branch
blocks, axis deviation, as well as like you know things that's axis deviation in
any particular direction might indicate. Same thing with our way progression,
hypertrophy, strain patterns, that sort of thing. And then the bottom we just have a
bunch of references for all the things that we sorted through to make this.
So that's what this is all about. This is I guess we call it our first draft of
this, our first go-around of kind of putting everything together into one
comprehensive document. So there's a good chance there are mistakes or typos along
the way. So if you see anything get in touch you can follow the link to our
website and check us out there. Let us know what you think about it and we'll
follow up one of these days with another version.